russia's war against ukraine has
uprooted millions of people particularly
in the south and east many have sought
refuge in other parts of the country
where the violence has been less intense
but it's not just people zoo animals
also need to be rescued from the
fighting and that's a logistical
challenge to bring them to safety as the
war rages dw's matthias berlinga reports
from odessa
these two refugees have seen terrible
things they were rescued from a zoo in
kharkiv the city in eastern ukraine that
has been shelled since the beginning of
the war
now they have found refuge here in
odessa
anybody
they were permanently under fire the zoo
suffered a lot animals were killed and
stuff as well it was very tragic
this is why the director of the zoo here
in odessa and his deputy loaded two
cages in a van and drove to harkev to
rescue the two lions
compared to the embattled city odessa
has been relatively safe during this war
the city has taken rocket hits but it
has not seen the same level of fighting
at the beginning of the war this zoo
closed like most institutions in ukraine
did but after a month they decided to
reopen to the public
and people are taking up the offer
inside the gates it's almost as if there
was no war outside
something needs to be operational we
need to take the kids out from time to
time and the animals need to be fed we
came here to support the animals and to
see the new pets from kharkiv
the zoo has not only taken in carnivores
from other zoos in a side building
hundreds of rabbits hamsters and guinea
pigs have found a temporary home
in the first days of the war the zoo
told citizens it would take care of
their loved
ones people found themselves at an
impasse imagine a woman fleeing the city
with her children and with suitcases
there's simply no way they would be able
to take their parrot on top of all that
that's why we decided to offer people
help with this impossible decision and
take in their pets
situated at the heart of the city the
zoo is an institution in odessa
and director beljakov is a well-known
public figure
in wartime the role of the zoo in
society is even bigger we not only have
to take care of our animals we also have
to cheer up our citizens
and the visitors are up for it when a
calf was born just after the zoo
reopened the onlookers were quick to
pick a name for her the creature is
called javelina named after the javelin
messiahs that have been instrumental in
defending the country